continuing on with fighting for the work
suppose you're working with someone that
come to you and you either have someone
who's very sort of a self-deprecating
almost mouse-like
or someone who's more of an
overconfident braggart either ones
probably detrimental to getting their
work out yes so what are your rules for
sort of either breaking down the
braggart or maybe you're not or boosting
up the mouse well with with the mouse I
just talked to one such mouse this
morning who takes every failure every
now as a testament to her own lifelong
predestined failure and so I have very
hard brutal conversations about the fact
that there there will be a lot of
rejection there will be a lot of noes at
every level at every level of this
industry nothing is ever perfect nothing
has ever just handed to you and so it's
important to me to have a lot of candid
conversations about learning not to take
the nose with quite as much weight
because if you do it's just never ending
right it's just a recipe for disaster so
we talked a lot about conviction in the
work believing in your work believing in
your potential not needing to rely on
other people for your own self-worth
because really that's what it boils down
to and so we talk about that a lot and
we talked about fattening up people's
lives so making sure that my writers who
are mousey have their sources they're
dependable sources of fun that it's not
all about the writing all the time
because the other side of it is if it's
just the writing if it's all about the
writing all the time and nothing else
eventually they'll have nothing else to
invest in the writing itself they'll
have nothing to bring to the writing so
it's really kind of filling out their
lives and making sure that they're
fulfilled on many different levels and
it's not just the writing that defines
them because if it's only the writing
that defines you a you will become a
very boring writer and B it'll never be
fulfilling enough ever and I've seen
that a million times
Hemingway committed suicide you know
that there's something to learn there
and so the ones who are tend to be a
little bit more braggy tend to be a
little bit more
Mystikal a little bit more full of
themselves will talk a lot about how
their behavior is coming off and I will
do a lot of meeting prep with them and
talk about you know the way that you're
talking about that to me comes off a
certain way and you may want to pay
attention to these things that's why I'm
here I'm here to reflect that and be a
mirror to those things and so we'll
certainly talk about how those things
come off and that we can't afford that
nobody wants to work with somebody who
is just completely full of themselves I
had recently a conversation with a
manager about a client of mine that he
represents and he says you know I think
this client is just couldn't care less
about my opinion and I said well
actually I think it's quite the contrary
I think that he's desperate to impress
you and I think because of that he may
be coming off a little bit bigger and
more boastful but it's out of
desperation to get you on his side to
get you to rally behind him it's not for
lack of respect it's because of respect
that he's behaving that way so many
times writers don't have me as a
go-between to communicate to their agent
or their managers or the executive that
they're working with so a lot of it is
me talking to them about listen this is
how I'm reading you right now I know it
doesn't sound fun and I'm sorry to say
this and I love you and I know what a
great person you are but this is how I'm
reading this is this how do you want me
to read this because if you're fine with
it
keep going but I'm reading your behavior
as that of one who is smarter than
anybody else in the room nobody wants to
work with that can I hear some examples
let's suppose conversations with the
self-deprecating writers conversations
with a braggart because maybe this
person doesn't recognize who they are a
bragger the most obvious and overt ones
are the braggers that will come in and
say and these are usually not
professional writers because
professional writers don't do this and
have learned better and have broken
because they don't but it has happened
this is the greatest script you're ever
going to read that's a big statement I'm
the Michael Jordan of screen right
whoa hold on I've had these are things
that have been said to me for the record
you know this this is the script you've
been waiting for take the script from
and Tony wants to take the script on
vacation this is my vacation gift to you
oh how kind read it I want you to sit at
sunset and read it on the veranda
because this will make your vacation
great so those things have been said to
me you know you want to steer clear of
this is the grater this is the best
script ever you can certainly say this
is the greatest thing I've ever written
I'm really proud of it I've worked
really hard at it you know I have eight
scripts behind me and this is my best
one that's not better bribery that is
genuine but somebody coming in and
saying oh my god this is so much better
than anything else out there
I had one writer working writer no
longer working writer who used to be
very very successful I had fallen from
grace a bit not a great deal but who
used to every year write a list of all
the screenplays that were nominated for
Academy Awards and then write arguments
for white why his script was better and
send it out in Christmas cards oh yeah
Wow I'm not a good idea that's not a
good idea if you're saying to me that
your script that's unproduced that
nobody wanted to pick up that has been
read by everybody but nobody loved it is
better than Argo
you're sure it's a problem so that's you
know that's the Baraga aside and of
course the examples I brought in are a
little bit on the extreme side of it but
I think you get the tone of it you know
the most the more self defeating
defeating writers it usually is
conversation about I got this rejection
I know that I will never be the person I
want to be there's usually a direct
connection about what rejection means
about that person not about the script
or the person reading the script I'm not
gonna make it as a writer I will never
be happy I will never be fulfilled I'm
just to lose her I didn't make it in
this contest I can't tell you the rhyme
or reason of screenwriting contests I've
been in this industry forever and I
still don't understand them and I have
writers saying oh I I didn't make the
quarterfinals in the nickel on the loser
I know that I'm a loser now I'm a bad
writer hold on there's gonna be lots
more rejections there's gonna be lots
more opportunities to be a loser don't
jump at the chance so quickly but for a
lot of writers it's very real and done
me wrong every writer has a moment or 15
of being self defeatist
you know I have one writer who's a
working writer who always says that if
you're not thinking about quitting at
least twice a week you're doing
something wrong and I believe them I
think it's very very true I think every
writer thinks they're failing at a
moment every writer thinks that they're
not good enough
every writer thinks that they're never
going to be able to recreate the past
success that they've had I think that's
perfectly part of the deal but seeing
everything as a failure as an indication
that you are just a loser you are just a
bad writer or you are just a bad person
that is what I see in the more self
defeated defeated writers and the
problem is that nobody wants to work
with that nobody wants to be in a room
with that nobody wants to pick up your
script as a validation to who you are as
a human being they want to pick up your
script because it's a great script and I
want to bring you into the room because
they think you have something to
contribute not because they think that
you need the room and that's that's a
big distinction so are you giving these
people pep talks or that's not really
what your job is about oh I give people
pep talks I'm I'm Israeli I'm married to
New Yorker so there's a lot of tough
love in the picture you know admittedly
I get a lot of tears from a lot of
people and I want to be the safe space
to that and the place for writers to
voice frustrations and I certainly try
to support them through it you know
they're writers where if I see that
we're getting to a place where every
time we meet it's just horrible and the
writer is in pieces
I will ask why in the world are you
doing this it's more important to be
happy than to be a writer
what are you doing so I will I will have
those conversations there are pep talks
there is tough love and there is a
shoulder to give I recognize that this
is a really really hard profession you
know I was talking to a writer this
morning who was really frustrated with a
set of notes that she had was given and
implement on a pilot that she just sold
but the draft that she turned and she
wasn't delighted with and it took a toll
on her because she really wants to do
the best at everything and it brought
her to question why am I doing this and
this is not her first time to the rodeo
and you know should I really keep going
because this happens every time and I
said to her you know what the day you
sold this pilot you called me on the
drive home after the pilots sold in the
room and he told me that this is one of
the happiest days of your life now
you're having a bad day this is not one
of the worst days of your life and
because of that you're gonna keep going
and that's the truth of the matter we're
all going to have bad days here and I'm
here to support my writers through them
but it's about understanding when there
are some bad days and when it's all bad
days
you